hello everyone and welcome back to the
good stuff we are continuing the 1858
clash between daniel harvest and paul
charles morphy
uh we've left it off after six game
games were played
then harvest said that he needed a break
or rather harvard said
that he needed a break after the fifth
game and then morphy said okay you can
have a break but then after we continue
the
the match uh we play at least one game
per day but then
after losing game six harvard said that
he is taking a break nonetheless
and morphy uh decided to take this
opportunity and he performed the
blindfold simultaneous exhibition
against
eight different opponents that we've
just covered so now we are returning uh
here for the match and the harvest
probably overheard that morphe was uh
having some difficulties he fell asleep
and near the window near and open the
window and he caught a bit of a cold
uh and the harvest took this opportune
opportunity to challenge
morphy uh to continue their match and
morphy of course
would not lose any time he wanted to he
wanted to continue the match regardless
of
uh of his health and um uh well
not only that after morphe uh uh
returned to the cafe de la regence to
continue the match harvest
was not there harvest insisted that the
games
uh continue in the room above uh where
uh where the uh well
where there will be no audience and this
was not
uh very well received by the audience
especially by harvest backers
as they were expecting of course to be
able to watch the games
at least and if you don't remember uh as
we've uh
we've taken a little bit of a break
during the morphe saga as we
usually do uh the match currently stands
as
four wins for morphe two wins for horror
it's harvard started the match by
winning two games but then
morphe won four games in a row uh if you
remember he said that harvey
horowitz will not win a single game
after after those two losses
so getting back to this game this is
game seven let's see what happens as
it's quite a nice one so harvest uh with
the white pieces
opens uh with d4 and morphe for the
third time in the official match or goes
for the dutch defense with f5
we have c4 e6 by morphe knight to c3 and
now
knight to f6 and bishop to g5 so similar
uh to all of the other games uh in game
three morphe
uh played bishop to b4 but here he
sticks the bishop to e7 this worked for
him uh very well in game five that
morphe also won
so here we have e3 uh morphe castles
bishop to d3 and b6 now morphy prepares
to fianchetto the light square bishop
uh knight g to e2 and he fianchetto said
bishop to b7
and if you remember in game five um
harvest just castled here
uh but here we have bishop captures on
f6 and it is uh only now as of move
eight that
this position has never been reached
again so
morphe recaptures bishop captures on f6
we have castles
uh and now queen to e7 just nicely
developing the queen
queen to d2 harvest does the same he
connects the rooks and
now d6 we have f4 by harvest again in
control of the e5 square
and not allowing morphe to ever push
that pawn so it will
remain kind of a backwards pawn on e6
but now morphy wants to weaken the
center and he strikes it
with c5 with d5 advancing the d-pawn
and now as morphe needs to figure out
how to develop his knight here he goes
knight to a6
uh we have d captures on e6 uh grabbing
that pawn
queen captures and now rook 8 e1
and here morphe just goes to bishop to
h4 asking harvest
uh do you want to block it with g3 which
kind of creates some additional
weaknesses or do you want to play knight
to g3
and then uh well just have a pin denied
because
you definitely don't want to move your
rock although rook the d1 might not be
all that bad
the the pawn is still on d6 so it's a
backwards pawn
so here at knight the g3 by harvest and
now queen to g6 by morphy putting
pressure on this knight
and harvest just goes knight to d5 e4 is
also a very nice idea here just trying
to take advantage of this
uh uh queen bishop relationship uh but
knight to d5 instead sort of trying to
trick morphe if he captures on g3 the 97
check just wins the queen
but of course morphe doesn't fall for
that morphe eliminates the knight
because it this is a very nice bishop
but as long as this knight is on d5 this
is not a very nice bishop so you might
as well yeah eliminate it
bishop captures on d5 we have c captures
and now
bishop captures on g3 we have h captures
and now you can't really pick up the
pawn because your knight is hanging so
uh knight to c7 morphy just shift shifts
tonight
and now comes king to f2 adding a
defender to the pawn here and
there really is no uh danger of uh
trying to grab this pawn because just
bishop c4
uh so here we have rook eight to e8
morphe brings the last rook into the
game
uh although uh since g3 pawn is a little
bit weak you might have some ideas of 98
knight f6 maybe knight h5 going after g3
but
this is too slow if you try something
like this white is much faster for
example e4 knight f6
and now e captures on f5 you just don't
have time to pull off
a plan like this and the best case
scenario it will yield maybe a draw a
knight g4
check king to e2 and now we could go
queen h5 check threat and some very
nasty discoveries here but
rook to h1 this is the problem and even
after rook 88
check we don't want to go here because
if this knight f2
check is a double check and then the
knight just picks up the rook
but we can most definitely play king to
f3
and then there are no issues here uh
there's nothing for you to win
uh you could deliver some double checks
here and here but it doesn't really do
anything
if you go for this check then just king
f2 and uh like i said best case scenario
you can go for
for a perpetual here but not something
morphy is interested in
so instead he just goes rook eight to e8
brings the final rook into the game
uh and now comes rook to h1 harvest now
uh the king nicely defending the the g3
pawn and he's hoping to maybe
maybe even double up rooks on the h file
who knows uh we've looked at e7 by
morphe now leaving this
uh well the ideas of this rook being
shifted to f7 or this one to e8
uh rook to h4 harvest uh also prepares
maybe uh doubling of the rooks but also
the rook is just a nice defender here
uh and now comes queen to f7 again if
you go for this pawn and i know a lot of
you were
uh you know thinking about this just
bishop the c4 and there's no defending
this
this knight so instead after rook to h4
we have queen to f7
preparing h6 and g5 morphy wants to
create some sort of a breakthrough here
and bishop back to e2 this bishop is now
being shifted
to f3 because you will need a defender
of the e4 square this knight is coming
to e8 to f6
and then to e4 the e4 and g4 squares are
just
you know a match made in heaven for for
for morphy's knight
so here uh like i said uh i
you do not want to go after this pawn i
have to repeat this again because white
just trades and then goes bishop c4 and
you lose a knight here
so after bishop to e2 with 98 morphy
continues with his plan of shifting the
knight
over to e4 and now queen to d3 you do
not want your queen and king like this
when the knight comes to e4 so queen d3
knight to f6 and now bishop to f3
just getting that bishop here adding
another defender to the e4 square
and now g6 by morphe first
preparing that h6 g5 we have rook to e2
and now rook f2 e8 shifting all the
attention to the e file
we have b3 uh move good as any it's
basically a waiting move
he has to see what morphe will do
because there really isn't all that much
white can do here
so queen g7 finally guarding the h6
square preparing h6 and g5 with rook
back to h1 doesn't want the rook to uh
uh be attacked here with with h6 and g5
and now morphe just continues with his
plan
we have king to g1 and g5
now we have captures captures in the now
bishop to h5 attacking the rook here
but morphy really doesn't care about
this rook he just goes knight to e4 and
this is a very deadly threat
because if you go after the rook then
queen to a1 check and this is basically
checkmate because
after you're done giving up all of your
pieces you have to play king to h2
and then just a rook h7 check and that's
it bishop blocks for example rook
captures an h5 will be checkmate
so after knight to e4 we have rook back
to e1 you have
to guard that a1 square but now rook to
f8 now morphe
will uh will of course save his rook and
the white
doesn't really have a good move here uh
there's no way to defend the g3 pawn the
f2 square is covered like we said by the
knight anymore like rook h3 just uh you
know
loses the the g4 and then the pawn gets
picked up
so here instead we have bishop back to
f3 and now morphy just eliminates it
knight captures on g4 a g3
and now morphy's position is really
really great he's up upon and the white
without any any serious uh plan here
uh so rook to h3 goes after the knight
here
uh and the queen to e5 now just
defending that knight with rook to h6
uh the rook doesn't really do all that
much here but you have to play something
and now
g4 pushing the bishop back we have
bishop back to d1
and now king to g7 pushing the rook back
we have rook to h4
and now rook to h8 morphe wants to
eliminate
harvest is uh basically last active
piece
so rook captures king captures and now
he will shift the other rook over to the
h file whereas harvest doesn't really
have all that much to do here
so here bishop to c2 another waiting
move not really
a lot you can do rook to h7 morphe is
free to
mount any sort of an attack here queen
back to d2 another waiting move and now
queen to b2 now pressuring this bishop
as uh
well not pressuring but pinning it as if
it moves then the queen falls
so rook to d1 adding a defender to the
queen but now
rook to h1 with check finally
king to f2 and now feel free to pause
the video here and win this game for
morphe
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on
not playing rook to f1 because this is
actually what morphe played
and for those who just want to enjoy the
show uh winning moves here uh
include both rook captures and d1 and
queen to e5 so those are all winning
point is that if you trade just trade
the rooks after queen captures you
you play some like queen e1 and this is
now a completely winning position for
black because
white again has no good moves here uh
you will just bring your king
all the way here and then just you know
play pretty much anything and you will
win this game
to give you an example white can only
play moves that
waste time uh for example king g7 we can
play a3
king to g6 we can play bishop d3
anything really king to g5
measure back to c2 and now knight to h5
we clear the
h2 square for the queen let's say bishop
d3
knight to f6 now bishop c2 white only
has
winning moves now queen h2 g3 is coming
and doesn't really matter
queen e2 you're gonna play queen to h1
and now
whatever because white has no moves i
have to i can't stress this enough
uh just g3 with check and you really
don't have any options here
uh you have to move uh you you will have
to capture this at some point so king
captures on g3
not just knight to e4 with check and now
if bishop captures for example queen h4
check king f3 and phone captures on e4
will be checkmate
all of the squares are now covered so
capturing with the rook is one way to go
about it
and just queen e5 is another way really
just for example if
white trades rooks just captures
captures with check king g1 knight g3
and we get a pretty much a similar
position where the
the you know game plan is pretty much
the same we bring the king over here and
win the game
however morphy played something
different after king qf2 morphe played
rook to f1 with
check the move from the thumbnail but
this simply doesn't work because after
rook to f1 check what morphe thought
would it happen
he thought brook captures here and then
i win the queen 94
check the king and queen are forked and
now after this uh bishop captures the
knight i'm going to capture the queen
and now it's queen against the bishop
and the rook or basically rather
after the king moves we're going to pick
up the bishop as well so it's completely
winning for morphe
uh but instead after this rook the f1
check
harvest said uh why thank you for the
three piece and harvest captured the
knight on g3 and
when morphy saw this morphe just burst
out laughing
he couldn't believe what he just did
because there were so many winning
options but
morphy i mean the position was so
dominant that
he decided that obviously everything was
winning but he just
missed that his knight was completely
hanging and now whether we
are gonna and attribute this to now
morphe having a fever or you know just
uh and uh
you know uh not being uh is so sharp
for the entire game because it's it's
very hard to stay sharp when you're so
so winning and you know a lot of moves
are winning then it's easy to blunder a
move like this
but uh that's not even the worst thing
the worst thing is that
uh after the game harvard said uh yeah
the game was pretty much
equal for for for you know for all of
the moves um
which was of course pretty silly because
the game was completely lost up until
this move but okay king captures and g3
was played
and now morphy is down a piece there's
really no way to continue this attack so
morphy played queen e5 check
king to h4 and now you can't really
continue unless you trade rook so here
morphe just repeated
queen f6 check king g3 queen to e5
checking h4 and queen to f6 morphy had
to do this
otherwise uh well you're just gonna be
down a piece and you're gonna lose the
game
so morphe unable to win uh the fifth
game in a row uh game seven ends in a
draw and it's remarkable that
harvest said that uh the the game was
pretty much equal
you know the the entire time and uh the
game uh
the match did not continue uh for uh the
next day because harvest again took a
break and he
you know still had to announce when a
game eight will be played but he was
still playing at the cafe de la regence
uh for the this entire time and the
morphe was left waiting to see when the
match will continue
so stay tuned uh there will be one more
game in this match and then we're gonna
discuss
what happens after that and you know uh
everything else so i'm gonna try to
cover this final game of this match
before the start of the candidates
so we get to you know concluded this
entire uh
trip to trip to paris and his match
against harvey's and the blindfold
simultaneous exhibition saga
uh before the the candidates uh start uh
so
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
morphe definitely didn't i mean playing
uh this
entire game feverish and then playing
rook to f1 i mean
it's just uh you know yes it's a
beautiful combination
unless uh you know yeah harvest just
wins the the free night but
what are you gonna do uh so yeah once
again hope you guys enjoyed it uh i
would like to thank richard lawrence
eat franco's dot com uh axel vermach uh
teophil bagor and
aristadis alambriani this for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the morphe
saga
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day